Maize or corn is one of the most widely grown grains in the world.
And as a staple in many of our diets,
but what you might not know is that the way that much of it is processed has
contributed to making millions of people sick and killing hundreds of thousands
over the past 500 years. I'm Dr. Bill Schindler, food, archeologists,
chef and director of the Eastern shore food lab at Washington college,
our modern approach to food processing,
which prioritizes convenience and profit over safety and nutrition has
negatively impacted the nutritional value of maze for our human bodies. However,
there is a process that will transform maze into its most nutritious and
delicious form, but that process has yet to be adopted by most of the world.
And that's what we're going to talk about today.
Geological evidence suggests that maize domestication may have started thousands
of years ago in the boss's Valley of Mexico.
It comes from a wild grass known as Teo Senti.
And these right here are grains from the wild Taya scent. They plant now,
archeologists are not even sure why maize domestication even started in the
first place. Was it for food? Was it for the alcohol they create out of it?
Was it for some utilitarian purpose or was it for something else altogether?
What we do know is that the genetic mutations that have occurred have
transformed wild PEO synthy grains into Temaze. As we know it today,
for example,
early versions of Mays had colonels that were individually wrapped just like
this. This required a tremendous amount of time and labor to harvest.
So early farmers were able to genetically modify maze to produce a cob covered
by one husk. Like we know it today.
These types of transformations increase the volume of food and decrease the
amount of work necessary to access that food. However,
maze is one of the most difficult grains in the world for our human digestive
tracks to fully break down and from which to derive the maximum amount of
nutrition,
it is very high in cellulose and insoluble fiber that our bodies can not break
down.
And some of the nutrients exist in forms that our bodies just can't access.
However,
early farmers discovered a process known as [inaudible], which provided their
bodies access to that nutrition.
Originally this process involves steeping kernels of maze in a solution of water
and wood Ash, but over time,
what Astros replaced with lye and even pickling lime,
but the process remains the same.
The mixture of a base with water creates an alkaline solution,
which chemically and physically transforms the maze into its safest and most
nourishing form possible for our digestive tracks.
Ms. Thomas station has many benefits. For instance,
it detoxifies grains and neutralizes. Anti-nutrients such as phytic acid.
It raises the calcium content by up to 400% increases,
the protein quality improves the amino acid balance and releases niacin from
niacytin it's natural form,
which is bound up and otherwise unavailable to our bodies. Finally,
it makes the greens easier to grind and transforms the flavor,
aroma and texture. Ms.
[inaudible] maze produces miss Tamo and grinding.
This tamale produces a dough known as Masa from Masa.
A number of different traditional foods can be made such as tortillas tamales,
and even the drink known as a totally when made properly using
traditional processing. These foods are incredibly nourishing today,
mazes in almost every process food,
and it's a staple for people around the world. However,
in modern food processing,
the crucial Ms. Thomas realization process is almost always skipped over
outside of areas with ancient ties to maize production. In fact,
many food producers likely don't even know it's a possibility when this Thom
realization is skipped,
much of the mazes nutrition remains locked up and inaccessible to our bodies.
No matter how we cook it. When we eat maize like this,
we're literally passing nutrients from our food,
through our bodies and into our waste.
Uh.
This widespread absence of niche,
Thom realization in maize processing has even led to more serious problems
across the globe.
There is a disease called palabra caused by a deficiency of niacin in the diet
that produces symptoms such as red, scaly skin, diarrhea,
dementia, and in advanced stages,
even death over the past several hundred years,
as maze has spread around the world,
this disease has followed in its wake because maze is incredibly cheap and
filling it regularly dominates diets often to the exclusion of other food and
essential nutrients cultures that become over-relying on maize maze that has not
been [inaudible] do not have access to all of the nutrition that it contains as
a result,
millions of people around the world ate massive quantities of maze became
deficient in niacin and palabra ran rampant. Just think about how crazy that is.
People around the world are getting sick and dying from a nice inefficiency
while eating large amounts of a food that contains an ice.
While this might not be a big concern for you in your area.
There are still places that rely heavily on Mays experiencing this problem.
In the early 20th century, millions of Americans got palabra,
which resulted in the deaths of hundreds of thousands.
When we realized what the problem actually was instead of adopting the practice
of [inaudible]. We made the decision to artificially enriched
foods with niacin. When we artificially enrich our food, we're addressing one symptom, but we're missing the much larger underlying problem. Yes, it provides us with niacin, but we miss out on all the other benefits of
[inaudible]
. And just as importantly, we miss out on the opportunity to connect with a
traditional practice that has such incredible cultural stigma.
The demand of an ever-increasing population scientists are developing things
like new insecticides and genetic modifications to increase maize production,
but before taking such drastic measures,
I wonder if we shouldn't first do everything that we can to make the most of the
maze that we're already growing and harvesting since maze is the most widely
grown grain in the world.
Just think about the impact that [inaudible] every single kernel of it
would have on our food supply.
There are choices that you can make and things that you can do to make a
difference, make a statement with your paycheck and support small tortilla,
RIAs,
and local food producers who are doing everything possible to produce safe,
nourishing food. Remember tortillas contain one ingredient.
[inaudible] mates refuse to purchase tortillas that contain dozens of
ingredients or better yet [inaudible] maze and make tortillas from scratch in
your own kitchen. For millions of years,
our ancestors developed technologies and approaches to food to make it safe,
nutrient dense and bioavailable,
but most modern food processing does the exact opposite today.
For the first time in the history of the world,
we can create obesity and malnutrition in the same individual.
That means the process food that we're eating is so free of nutrients that
we can eat. Massive quantities of it, and still be malnourished.
This isn't just happening with maze.
It's happening in different ways throughout our food system. This is a problem.
We don't need new food innovations to solve early maize farmers solved this
problem. Thousands of years ago,
what we need to do is look to the past and incorporate those traditional
practices into our modern food system.